Welcome!
Thanks!
You ...
We saw some images of you when you were 15, now you're 16.
From the climate conference in Poland.
What was that like for you ...
... to speak there and to be there? Was it impressive seeing ...
... how this climate work happens, close by?
It was definitely an incredible opportunity to be able to be there.
Not a lot of people are allowed to be there.
But it's quite depressing being there, because you think that ...
Our future is in the hands of these people.
And they don't seem to take that seriously.
That makes you pretty scared.
In what way?
They are there, after all.
Yes, but it feels like they ...
They don't really want to be there, in a way.
They're only there because it's a UN conference.
It doesn't feel real.
In the dining room, everyone eats hamburgers, for example, and that ...
Okay?
There's not a lot happening, it's mostly talk.
You weren't more optimistic when you left than when you came?
No, I wasn't. But it was still very cool to be able to speak in front of everyone, to ...
... to have something to say and to have it said.
You ...
This has made a huge impression.
But it's an involvement that ...
... you've had a while now.
Can you remember ...
... how this involvement began with you?
How it began?
It was ...
Some years ago, I might have been ...
8 or 9 years old, I went to elementary school and ...
And my teachers were talking about climate change, and hoe we should turn off the lights when we left the room, and ...
... that we should save water.
And things like that.
And I remember one instance when we were watching a movie about plastic in the ocean.
And climate change. And then ...
We watched the movie, and then ...
I cried through the movie, and the other children were of course also very affected.
And when the movie was finished, the teacher immediately after said:
«Next week you'll have a substitute teacher, because I'll be at a wedding in New York.»
And I thought ...
«They just said that airplanes was a cause, how can they say that and still ...»
«... fly.»
And I thought it was very strange that they could say one thing and do another, because I'm a person who ...
... doesn't like saying one thing and doing another, so ...
It sparked an interest in me, and I started reading.
I borrowed books and ...
Saw movies. Read articles. And ...
The more you read, the more you understand.
And when you understand ...
... the climate crisis, you can't ...
... escape, then you're stuck.
Do you think that that is ...
... part of the problem, that ...
... a lot of people don't fully understand the climate crisis?
Yes, absolutely. Most people don't understand ...
Most people know that the planet is getting warmer because of greenhouse gasses.
Caused by our emissions.
And that that can lead to ...
... ice melting, more extreme weather and it getting warmer.
But they don't know the consequences of that.
And how serious it actually is. And they don't know ...
... what it takes to prevent it.
You have been open about having Asperger's.
In what way has that affected you in this case ...
... would you say, when it comes to your climate interest?
It think it has affected everything.
Because if ...
If I didn't have Asperger's and if I wasn't so strange, I would be stuck in this ...
... social game that everyone else seems to be so infatuated with.
But ...
It makes me function a bit differently. I see the world in a different way, with a different perspective.
And I think that if I didn't have this, then I wouldn't ...
... have been able to see it from the outside.
I see things very much as black and white.
And most people say that: «It doesn't matter if I do a little of this. Nothing is black and white.»
But the climate question is actually black and white.
In one way, it's the most complicated question that exists, and it will take ...
...a  huge effort to stop it.
But the solution is still simple enough for a five-year-old to understand.
We have to stop the emissions. It's black and white.
Because either we will start a chain reaction ...
... that triggers events that triggers events beyond human control ...
Or we don't.
Does that mean that you ...
We have an expression in Norwegian that says «live what you teach».
Do you do that yourself?
Can you manage?
Yes, I hope that I do. I have ...
... stopped flying ...
... become a vegan, and I have a «shopping stop», which means that I don't buy new things.
And that ...
That's a choice I've made because I can't stand up for these ...
... causes without doing my part.
If not I would have such a bad conscience.
You have ...
... two parents ... And your mother is a famous opera singer, Malena Ernman.
Have they been affected, have they changed their lifestyle?
Eh. Yes.
I made my parents stop flying some years ago.
And especially since my mother is dependent ...
... or was dependent, on flying for work, she was forced to change her career, in some way.
Because she's a very famous singer, with a big career?
But ...
That doesn't help, the excuse is too poor?
Yes. She does musicals instead now, in Stockholm.
Do they shop, then?
Definitely not as much as they used to, but ...
It does happen that they do.
Do they then try to keep it hidden from you?
To hide away ..?
Yes.
But I ...
It's difficult to hide things from me, I can tell when people are lying.
And then ...
And then they have to tell me, and I will scold them.
So you walk around the house like a sort of police?
Mhm!
And i go through their receipts!
You do?!
Sometimes, yes!
You've said that ...
... that this involvement with the climate has made you well.
Mhm.
In what way were you unwell?
Some years ago ...
I became depressed.
I could only stay at home.
I stopped going to school. And ...
I stopped eating, stopped talking.
Because I felt that there was no meaning with life.
So then ...
Why did this happen?
I don't know. There were a number of reasons. But one reason was ...
... climate change. And ...
... what is happening to the environment and the climate. That ...
It was happening, and no one cared. That ...
Our society is so shallow. We only focus on ...
... what's on the surface, instead of ...
... what is happening on the inside. And ...
Everything goes so fast. The hamster wheels turn faster and faster, and then ...
I fell off these hamster wheels, in some way. And then ...
And I saw it from the outside and thought: «This is wrong.»
That we can't continue like this, because you don't end up anywhere on a hamster wheel.
There's so much on the outside.
And you feeling better, does that have to do with your involvement and that you've become more active..?
Yes.
Yes, absolutely. Because ...
I realized in some way that there's so much to live for. There's so much ...
One can try to improve the world and ...
... make a difference. And I thought that I would try to do just that.
You've received a huge amount of attention for this ...
... not least because you started a school strike that has been copied all around the world.
There are strikes all over the world.
Yes.
There have been strikes inn all continents except Antarctica!
Which is ...
I'm still waiting!
The penguins are a little behind?
Yes. They need to catch up!
But it's very cool that it has spread out all over the world.
Literally. There have been ...
... tens of thousands of people, mainly young people, who have ...
... gathered in front of parliaments or town halls.
And you're still doing this.
How long are you planning to sit there and keep doing this?
Until Sweden is in line with the Paris agreement.
And that can take a few years.
One should be patient.
When it's like now, with around minus 10 degrees celcius in Stockholm ...
... do you sometimes regret the method you've chosen?
Sometimes, maybe. When you have to ride a bike in minus ten degrees.
Early in the morning. Then you might think that ...
But, no.
No, because you can see that i still makes a little bit of a difference, and ...
You need to wear layers. Lots of layers. And you can bring tea. And you can jump!
Greta, next week, you're heading to the ...
... big economic forum in Davos.
You're going to meet Bono, amongst others. And I know that John Kerry, the former Secretary of State to the US, has asked for you to come.
And then you're going to Rome to speak in front of the Pope.
When you travel to Davos ...
That is a place where most people arrive in their private jets, at least quite a lot of them.
How will you travel there?
Train. The night train.
In total, I think it will be 65 hours back and forth.
But then you can make sure you have things to do on the train, like writing speeches and things like that.
Good luck with that, I'm so happy to have you in the show tonight.
We're going to welcome another guest. Thank you so much!